je comprends très bien le pen c'est pas
très facile à porter je le dis
franchement mais moi qui a un nom un peu
connue pour mes enfants c'est quoi votre
nom
pour eux parfois c'était un peu gênant
ouais je pense que pour vos seront
séparés hanouna si la tension monte à
l'école c'est vrai c'est vrai que quand
on est connu il faut protéger ces
enfants et c'est toujours compliqué
parce que d'un côté on en met deux ils
vont ramener un peu de les montrer et
c'est vrai que mes enfants en ont
beaucoup souffert et ont
déjà eu
interdisait aux enfants de lui parler
qu'est ce qui les réunit c'est quelqu'un
qui fait partie des leçons qu'on va
ramener bien sûr à la sortie très
rapidement eu c'est assez étonnant mais
c'est vrai c'est quelqu'un c'est est ce
qu'il est parfois des problèmes c'est
des fauteurs de troubles oui les
problèmes parfois à cause de leur nom
oui bien sûr il aurait été un peu
arsenal sur quoi à barcelone les cas où
les éleveurs tellement on en a parlé
beaucoup ici cela que ils sont et sont
la cible de toutes les attaques et là ça
devient très compliqué - on a sorti l
mes enfants de l'école ont là on l'a
changé d'école pour voyez quoi ils
étaient mérités madoff savait qu'il
était harcelé il revenait voilà on s'est
rendu compte qu'il allait pas bien qui
n'auraient pas bien il a fini par dire
ça se passe pas bien à l'école et ce qui
était un fossé que les profs n'ont pas
du tout ni des toiles y aider on en a
parlé souvent c'est à ces assassins le
point de tomber le castel dit imaginer
ce qu'il a vu ce qu'il a pu dire mais
bon ce pas il appelle le pen s'est
certes c'est encore pire c'était parfois
un côté pernikoff